المترجم: Muna Kambal
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
إن حياتنا عبارة عن كاريكاتير كبير
هكذا كنت أرى الدنيا منذ سن صغير
أي موقف يمر بي أعبرعنه بالرسم
إذا مر بي موقفٌ ما في المنزل، فكنت اقوم
برسم ملامح الناس بإضافة بعض المبالغات
بعض الأشخاص اقوم برسمهم
بأذنين كبيرين أو أنف كبير
واُعبر عن هذا الموقف بمشهد كوميدي معين.
أود الآن أن أعرفكم على هذا الشخص
الذي بالصورة، إنه انا قبل حوالي 20 عاماً
عمري آنذاك كان عامين أو ثلاث تقريباً
كنت كثيرالشغب ومتعباً لأهلي
كثيراً ما كنت أقوم بممارسة هوايتي المفضلة
بالرسم في الحوائط والأبواب وكل ما حولي،
وأثير حفيظة إخوتي بالرسم على كراساتهم
المدرسية، لذا كنت مصدرقلق دائم بالنسبة لهم
الى أن حصلت في إحدى الأيام على علبة ألوان
ومعها كراس لرسم كل ماياتي بخاطري.
حسناً، إذن
دائما كان أهلي يسألونني ماذا تريد أن
تصبح عندما تكبر، فأرد أود أن أصبح رساماً،
فكانت أُمي دائماً تقول لي: "ماذا، رساماً؟
أنت سوف تدخل الكلية وإذا ما سألني الناس،
"ماذا يعمل ولدك،
هل أرد بأنك تشخبط وهكذا،
إنه لشى مشين أن أجلس مع جاراتي
وأقول لهم هذا، لايمكن هذا،
ماذا ستصبح بعد أن تتخرّج، واللوحات
هل ستبيعها في الشارع؟ هل ستشحد بها؟" المهم
فكلما يسألونني وأرد بأنني سأصبح رسامً.
اُواجه بالإستهزاء وأصاب بالإحباط للأسف.
حسناً،
مرت الأيام ودخلت المدرسة، فكان أي موقف
يحصل لي مع أصدقائي، أرسمه على ورق
وبملامح مبالغٌ بها، وتمرالورقة على جميع
من بالفصل وكانوا دائماً ما يضحكون منها.
وفي أحد الأيام، أحد أصدقائي حصل
له موقف مع الأستاذ فرسمت الموقف
ولكن يبدو أنه تضايق من ضحك الزملاء عليه،
فمباشرة أخذ الورقة وذهب إلى الأستاذ بمكتبه
قائلاً: "يا أستاذ هذا الشخص قام برسمي"
فأخذ الاستاذ الورقة وجاء الى الفصل،
وعندها أحسست بالخوف وبأنني ساُعاقب
وسوف يتم استدعاء ولي أمري، فكنت أرقب خطى
الأستاذ وهو متجه نحوي وانا خائفٌ جداً،
فدخل الأستاذ الفصل، تصنعت الأدب،
عندما اقترب مني أحسست كأن كفاً سوف يقع علي
(ضحك)
ولكن حصلت ردة فعل غربية،
مدّ لي الاستاذ الورقة سائلاً: "هل أنت
من رسم هذا؟" فأجبت: "نعم انا من رسمها "
وهذا طبعاً المنظرالذي توقعته
بأن الأستاذ سيعاقبني
ولكن حصلت رده فعل غربية ألا وهي
أنه اثنى على رسمى قائلا: "ماشاءالله،
أنت تتمتع بأسلوب معين في رسم الناس وهكذا،
وأنا مسؤول عن جمعية التربية الفنية
وأود أن تكون أحد الأعضاء
في جمعية التربية الفنية بالمدرسة."
فكنت أنظرله باستغراب،
لأنها ردة فعل لم اتخيلها.
فكانت هذه هي البداية، فقد وجدت أناساً
بيني وبينهم شيئ مشترك ويرسمون مثلي وهكذا.
وقد شاركت بعدة مسابقات باسم المدرسة،
وأذكر آخرها كانت مسابقة الرسم الحر،
حيث تم إعطاؤنا أوراقاً بيضاء
وطلب منا رسم أي شي نريده
فأذكر في هذة المسابقة أنني
حصلت على المركز الاول
على مستوى إمارة مكة المكرمة حيث كنت
أدرس بالمملكة العربية السعودية.
(تصفيق)
وكانت هذه دفعة معنوية قوية لي
للإستمرار في الرسم الكاريكاتيري.
استمرت مرحلة المدرسة ووصلت الثانوية وللأسف
لم يكن هناك أي نشاط للتربية الفنية بها
فكنت متضايقاً جداً ومحبطاً لأنني لم أجد
مساحة للتعبيرعما بداخلي في هذه المرحلة.
وكان الناس منقسمين العلمي
في دارسته، كذلك الادبي وهكذا
فكنت متضايقاً جداً في هذه الفترة إلى أن
وصلت مرحلة التقديم للجامعة.
وكانت رغبتي محددة مسبقاً، وكل من حولي
يدرون بأن محمد يود الدخول لكلية الفنون.
فقلت لهم إن أول رغبة
لي هي الدخول لكلية الفنون.
وأثناء جلوسي مع والدتي ومشاورتها
في الموضوع
كانت تردد نفس كلامها السابق: "ماذا كلية
فنون! ماذا ستفعل بها؟"، فاُحبطت مجدداً.
فأجبتهم: "بما أنكم قضيتم على رغبتي هذه،
فليس لي خيار آخرغير التقديم لكلية الهندسة
لما تحويه من رسم وتصميم." وهكذا.
وللأسف بما أنني جلست لامتحان الشهادة
من السعودية، فعندما حضرت إلى السودان،
تم خصم 10% لمعادلة الشهادة
مع الشهادة السودانية.
فللأسف النسبة لم تكن لتدخلني كلية الهندسة،
فكنت يائساً ومحبطاً وقدمت في أي رغبة
فتم قبولي بكلية العلوم الرياضية
وهي كلية عكس اهتماماتي تماماً.
كانت كليةً مليئة بالحساب وأذكر أني دائماً
ما أخرج من قاعة الدراسة،
أشتكي من الصداع من العمليات الرياضية وهكذا
وعندما اُسأل ماذا بي، كنت أرد
بانني أشتكي من الشد العضلي بالمخ
من الكم الهائل من المسائل
التي لا أستطيع تحملها.
وأذكر أن هذه المرحلة مرت برتابة شديدة
لم أستطع معها ممارسة هوايتي،
برسم ما يدور حولي وتوصيل فكرتي عن الناس،
إلى أنه في أحد الأيام، أذكر أنني
كنت دائماً ما أفرغ ضغوط المحاضرات
بعد الإنتهاء منها، بقلب كراستي وأرسم
على الصفحة الأخيرة الأستاذ وطريقة
شرحه للمحاضرة وهكذا.
فأذكر في أحد الأيام وأنا أرسم
أن زميلتي التي تقربني
قالت لي: "يا مُحمد هل أنت
من قام برسم هذة اللوحة؟"
فأجبتها: "نعم أنا" فقالت لي: "نحن نريد
إقامة معرض الأسبوع القادم ونود أن تشاركنا"
وسألت إن كنت أمتلك مجموعة من اللوحات
كي أشارك بها، فأجبتها بنعم
وعندما جاء الأسبوع الثقافي للكلية، وعرضوا
عدد من لوحاتي، مع أنني لم أكن مهتماً جداً
وكل ما توقعته أن ياتي الناس يتفرجون على
اللوحات ويذهبون، ولكن حصل مالم أتوقعه،
كانت ردود أفعال من زار
المعرض إيجابية جداً ومشجعة،
وأذكُر أن أحد الأشخاص نصحني
بالتقديم في الصحف السودانية.
فأذكر أنني ذهبت لعدد من الصحف وأجريت
عدة مقابلات عرضت خلالها لوحاتي.
فدائماً كانوا يثنون على رسوماتي وكانوا
يعطونني أرقاماً لمعاودة الإتصال بهم قريبا.
وحين أعاود الإتصال بهم أجده مغلقاً.
(ضحك)
للأسف كان مقلباً فهم لا يريدون إعطائي
فرصة معهم بالصحيفة كي لا اُضايقهم في عملهم
وكردة فعل غضبت جدًا من هذا التصرف
حيث حدثت لي من عدة صحف ذهبت للتقديم بها.
وكانت ردة فعلي أن قمت بإنشاء
صفحة على الفيس بوك أسميتها
ما ترونه الآن هو معرض الكلية.
حسناً، هناك صورة كان من المفترض
عرضها هنا ولكن لم تعرض.
أنشأت صفحة الفيس بوك وأسميتُها
"الكاريكاتيريست محمد إسماعيل."
ووضعت عنواناً هو أنني شخص سوداني
من جملة الشعب السوداني وأود أن أضع بصمتي
في مجال الكاريكاتير، وأن المناخ السوداني
يعتبر بيئة خصبة لأفكاري هذه.
فدائماً أي موقف يمر بي في الشارع أو حتى في
المواصلات العامة، كنت اُرسمه وأنزله بصفحتي
وخلال فترة وجيزة جداً وصل عدد المعجبين
بصفحتي إلى 13 الف معجب.
ومن خلال هذه الصفحة تلقيت عدة اتصالات
من الصحف التي كنت أذهب لها سابقاً.
أخبروني أن لديهم صحيفة جديدة
ويريدونني أن أكون معهم
فذهبت حينها وأنا غير مصدق ومضيت العقد
وباشرتُ عملي من اليوم التالي بالصحيفة.
فكان هذا شيئاً جيداً جداً بالنسبة لي.
ولاحقاً لم أحصر نفسي في مجال الكاريكاتير،
بل تعلمت مهارات جديدة في الرسم.
كان رسمي دائماً يعتمد على الورق،
والآن إستغنيت عن الورق نهائياً
وكل رسمي أصبح رقمياً وهكذا
وهذا فتح لي كثيراً من الأفاق
لم أكن لأتخيلها مطلقاً
أنا الآن مصمم جرافيك وأعمل على عدة
وسائط ملتيميديا ومعه عمل مونتاج.
وعملت مع بعض الأشخاص الذين
لديهم شركة إنتاج إعلامي
وجائتني فكرة وهي أن بدلاً عن عمل بروفات
كثيرة لماذا لا نحول أي فكرة إلى قصص مصورة،
ثم نراجع هذة القصص المصورة
ومن ثم نصورها مرة أخرى،
وهذة الطريقة ساعدتنا جداً حيث قللت
الأخطاء وأتممنا العمل بكفاءة عالية جداً.
والحمدلله سار العمل على نحو جيد.
الرسالة التي أود إيصالها للناس،
أن الله سبحانه وتعالى لم يخلق
الموهبة داخل الإنسان عبثاً
بل خلقها بداخلك كي تؤدي وظيفة بالمجتمع،
وتخدم المجتمع بما لديك من مهارة.
فأنصح أي شخص بتخصيص مساحة
وزمن لممارسة هواياته وهكذ.ا
حالياً من الأشياء التي أنجزتها أحسّ أنني
أتممت أقل من 1% مما أود إنجازه،
وما زال لدي الكثير من الأفكار
والمشاريع للقيام بها بنسبة 99%
وفي الختام، أريد ان أقول لكم
أن أي شخص في هذة الدنيا يحيا مرة واحدة
فلماذا لا تكون أفضل حياة ممكنة؟"
وشكراً.
(تصفيق)